for every horror movie drawn from a
screenwriter's imagination
there's an equal number that has been
adapted from works of literary fiction
and short stories in particular seem to
be particularly well suited for a big
screen debut
here are the most frightening horror
movies based on short stories
one of the most ferocious horror films
of the 1980s
hellraiser was adapted by author turned
director clive barker from his own 1986
novella
the hell-bound heart barker has said in
interviews that the reason he wrote and
directed hellraiser was to exert some
creative control over adaptations of his
work
having been displeased with the feature
film versions of rawhead rex
and what became of his own script for
underworld
as a result hellraiser closely follows
the plotline of hellbound heart with
only a handful of changes
for example in the novella kirsty is a
friend of the ill-fated rory whose
brother frank
accidentally summons the cenobites while
in the film
kirsty is the daughter of rory who is
renamed larry
the name of the diabolical puzzle box
that conjures up the cenobytes
is also slightly different in the
novella it's the lemarchel configuration
which barker dubs the lament
configuration in his script
and speaking of the cenobytes their s m
inspired body modifications are
for the most part almost identical to
their description in barker's story
right down to the massive pins in the
creature which while nameless in the
book and film would eventually become
known as pinhead
hp lovecraft's hugely popular 1927 short
story the color out of space
has been adapted to film several times
most notably
die monster die with boris karloff and
1987's
the curse the most recent and by many
accounts
best screen translation is 2019's color
out of space
directed by south african filmmaker
richard stanley
stanley's version sticks closely to
lovecraft's story which is about a
meteorite that crashes on a new england
farm
and unleashes bursts of unearthly color
that caused horrific mutations to the
farm's flora
fauna and family there are a few changes
here and there for example
stanley's script adds some dark humor
and a dash of modern angst about climate
to the story
most importantly though color out of
space nails one of lovecraft's core
concepts
that unimaginable monstrosities lurk
just beyond our realm of understanding
always waiting for the right opportunity
to unleash their horrors on the world
all three film versions of the thing owe
their existence to john w campbell's
novella
who goes there first published in 1938
in the magazine astounding science
fiction
the novella depicts the battle between a
research team in antarctica
and the shape-shifting occupant of a
nearby alien spacecraft
of the three film adaptations it's john
carpenter's
classic 1982 movie the thing
that most resembles the plot of
campbell's novella from which it borrows
character names
the iconic blood test sequence and the
alien's transformative abilities
notably however the story of the thing
didn't actually end with who goes there
in 2018 a box of campbell's manuscripts
were discovered which revealed that the
novella was merely the shortened version
of a longer novel
titled frozen hell curiously frozen hell
appears to be an earlier version of the
tale that would become
who goes there campbell had seemingly
hoped to write the story as a full novel
but when he failed to sell it he
re-edited it into a shorter form and
sold it to astounding science fiction
the new updated story was finally
published in 2019
and a year later blumhouse productions
announced that a film version of the
expanded story is in the works
why don't we just
wait here for a little while
[Music]
see what happens three stories by
british author daphne du maurier were
adapted into film by alfred hitchcock
the novel's rebecca and jamaica inn and
the 1952 short story the birds which hit
the silver screen in 1963.
du maurier was inspired after seeing a
farmer attacked by birds while plowing a
field
and retained that image for her story
which pits a cornish farmer against a
growing army of enraged birds
screenwriter evan hunter expanded upon
domori's story by moving the action to
the bay area
adding numerous characters and striking
a slightly more humorous tone for the
movie's early scenes
what both projects share however is the
lack of concrete
reason for the birds to actually revolt
du maurier's story suggests that the
birds are set off by changing weather
patterns
while hitchcock alluded in interviews
that the attack was nature's revenge on
men
neither is ever confirmed however which
only makes the phenomena
in both film and story all the more
chilling
one of the greatest screams in 50s
science fiction horror
comes in 1958's the fly in which a
brilliant scientist has his genes
crossed with a house flies
[Music]
author james clavell wrote the script
for kurt newman's film
but the idea itself came from the short
story of the same name
by french british writer george langlin
the story which appeared in the 1957
issue of playboy magazine
was adapted to film with very few
changes the primary differences included
the fact that langlen's story takes
place in france while newman's film is
set in canada
clavel also spared the protagonist's
wife played in the film by patricia
owens from the more macabre
fate suffered by the written version of
the character langolin's story was also
credited as the inspiration for
two so-so sequels return of the fly in
1959
and curse of the fly in 1965 as well as
for david cronenberg's 1986 remake
as it turned out however the latter
movie was only loosely based
on langolin's original story in fact
writer and co-director cronenberg
only really retained the concept of the
fly in the transporter device
in order to tell his terrifying and
instantly iconic
tale of body horror an oscar nominee for
best foreign language film in 1966
the 1965 japanese supernatural anthology
film qui-dan
draws inspiration from the work of
lofkario hearn hearn was a greek irish
writer who wrote extensively about
japanese myth in the late
19th and early 20th centuries and his
stories
introduced western readers to the vast
array of ghosts and creatures that
populated japanese folklore
four of those stories were adapted for
quite on which was directed with
stunning visual flair by art house
favorite masaki kobayashi
being over half a century old the scares
here are milder than what you might have
come to expect from jay horror movies
however both hearn and quiet on found
inspiration in a creature that will be
very familiar to fans of the genre
specifically the vengeful on ryu
featured in two of her
stories are similar to the revenge
obsessed spirits depicted in the ring
the one missed call series and countless
other japanese
ghost movies mario baba's 1963 anthology
film black sabbath attributes its three
tales of supernatural horror to stories
by three different authors
whose last names should be familiar to
avid readers of 19th century world
fiction
de mon paso chekhov and tolstoy
but things aren't quite what they seem
here the tolstoy credited with the
source material for the vertilock isn't
word peace author leo tolstoy
but his second cousin alexie tolstoy who
was better known for his plays
and it wasn't anton chekhov who penned
the inspiration for drop of water but
ivan chekhov
who isn't actually a real person at all
but something of a joke by bava and his
co-writers
as for guimo gitmopassal's involvement
in the telephone
some historians suggest that this is
again a fabrication
though bava historian tim lucas has
suggested that the episode bears a
passing resemblance to demopezzle's
story
the orla notably that latter story was
itself made into a movie
diary of a madman which starred vincent
price and was released
the same year as black sabbath no matter
who penned each story black sabbath is
one of bava's most
enjoyable and spine chilling works
thanks in no small part of course to the
legendary boris karloff
who both narrates the film and features
in the vertilock
richard matheson's name comes up
countless times in the history of horror
fantasy and science fiction in the 20th
century
he's linked to some of those genres most
influential and popular films and
television series
from the twilight zone and i am legend
to star trek and bid time return the
novel that became somewhere in time
matheson is also responsible in part for
helping to launch steven spielberg's
film career
with the 1971 tv movie duel
matheson adapted his own short story
published in playboy in 1971
for the abc movie of the week the script
about a motorist pursued by a faceless
and relentless trucker
caught the attention of spielberg who
earned huge ratings and
widespread critical praise for his
nail-biting mix of suspense
and motorized action in fact dual was so
popular that it was released to theaters
in international markets which in turn
helped to pave the way for spielberg's
motion picture career he later paid
tribute to the big break afforded by
duel
by inserting the truck's monster-like
roar into the finale of jaws
when the shark's body sinks into the
ocean
horror fans critics and filmmakers alike
have cited cult filmmaker nicholas
rogue's 1973 featured don't look now
as one of the best and most influential
supernatural thrillers of the 1970s
for the film alan scott and chris bryant
adapted the short story of the same name
written in 1971 by hitchcock favorite
daphne du maurier
don't look now stars donald sutherland
and julie christie as grieving parents
who come to believe that their late
daughter may be trying to warn them
about an impending threat
she's with you she's with you my dear
and she's laughing the script closely
follows the source materials storyline
including its shocking final revelation
and conclusion meanwhile rogue's unique
editing and color schemes have
influenced countless filmmakers over the
years
among the many filmmakers who have paid
homage to don't look now
is joel schumacher whose 1990 film
flatliners even features an overt
reference to the deadly figure in red
who features in rogue's film stuart
gordon's
re-animator features some of the most
gruesome scenes in
any horror film of the 1980s you might
be forgiven for thinking that
reanimator's more
outrageous moments were conceived by
gordon himself
but the source material hp lovecraft's
herbert west
reanimator is actually even gorier than
the movie
gordon's script streamlined lovecraft
story 2 which takes place over the
course of several years and even takes
its anti-heroes to the battlefields of
world war 1 in search of bodies to
reanimate
and the sheer nastiness of herbert west
is more than a match for gordon's
supercharged on-screen gore
west's reanimated subjects carry out
multiple killing sprees
and at one point even turn cannibal
lovecraft's story also features an
animated body without a head
which leaves a zombie army against the
west in the blood-soaked final chapter
if anything it seems like gordon
actually had to reel
in the violence for the movie version of
reanimator which is pretty remarkable
considering what did end up on screen
mgm's freaks has shocked and amazed
viewers since
its debut in 1932. the film directed by
todd browning
features actual sideshow performers in a
macabre gothic story of
love betrayal and revenge one that has
earned as much praise as it has
condemnation
numerous writers including uncredited
future oscar winner charles macarthur
worked on the script which was inspired
by todd robin's 1926 story
spurs but freaks isn't actually all that
similar to spurs anyone who reads the
actual story will find that very little
connects the two projects
beyond the carnival setting and the
ill-fated love triangle between three of
its performers
horror fans may also be disappointed to
find that the fate of the story's
so-called normal characters is somewhat
less disturbing than what happens to
trapeze artist cleopatra
and strongman hercules in browning's
film haven't seen the movie either
well let's just say things don't turn
out well
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one